well I'm joined Now by Iman ayton who's
organized her own black lives matter
protest including the likes of actor
John villega and Madonna and Royal
historian and author Sir Anthony Selden
so welcome to both of you this is a
really incendiary debate now never used
to be used to be just everyone used to
agree Winston Churchill was a national
hero who saved us from the Nazis and
that was it but now he's not and I'll
start Imam by saying this I understand
why young people look back at some of
the things that Churchill was recorded
as saying some of the views that he held
and I understand why it made color the
judgment about him literally actually
um but I also believe you should take
all great figures in totality I agree
whether it's Gandhi Mandela
Churchill whoever it may be and the
Welter of positives for Winston
Churchill to me outweigh attitudes and
occasional comments which were by far
the norm of that era
and not I wouldn't be tolerated today
and what's your reaction to that I
totally agree with you so I don't
actually hop on on the covert racism or
the kind of you know the comments like
black people are savages and you know
Indians are obesity race I don't
actually hold on to that because you're
right it was during those times not that
it's acceptable we can safely say it
wasn't what I hold on to for example is
yes he was a hero I think I was given
the same kind of narrative that most
people were that this is a British hero
um admittedly it was only when I saw
Churchill was a racist that graffiti
that was written on his statue during
black lives matter that prompted me as a
random person to say you know I'm going
to go home and research Winston
Churchill and in doing that I found the
two things that resonated with me
personally the first was the four
million Indians that died due to the
Bengal famine which was a direct result
of Winston Churchill's decision making
the second would happen
Okay I don't know fair enough but I'll
come back to you because that is simply
not true okay the mythology that's built
up around what happened and I'll let the
Great historian please fill in the
blanks here but the there's a lot of
Mythology that's been fermenting about
Churchill's culpability over the Bengal
family but for nothing else he didn't
cause the famine the famine was caused
by a cyclone it was then massively
exacerbated by a failure to get resource
and food into the area because of the
war and because of Japan's Stranglehold
on the area and so on and so on
Churchill did direct other countries
building America and Australia to try
and send grain to Bengal but he also
prioritized when it really came to it
British troops who were going to die of
hunger as well and as the British prime
minister in a war I'm not sure you can
sincerely blame him no which I've heard
and I totally agree so my point is it's
very easy to say that Churchill caused
the famine and the death of four million
people but actually when you get into
the Weeds about what happened there
that's simply not accurate historically
well I said it was due to his decision
making and secondly that's not the only
thing that resonated with me the second
thing that resonated with me with his
was the fact that he built Kenyan
concentration camps so please call me
and tell me I am wrong he built Kenyan
concentration camps seven years after
World War II seven years after defeating
fascism seven years after getting rid of
concentration camps for Jews he decided
after seven years of growth and learning
and all of this peace and all of this
amazingness that Britain has achieved
we're now going to build concentration
camps and not for Jews this time it's
going to be for Kenyans and we're now
going to start making pillars or or
sorry uh rather uh like these kind of
different instruments that literally
crush and rip the testicles off of
Kenyan men and we're going to do that
seven years after defeating okay so yes
I've got a different perspective we've
heard the view and it's a view clearly
shared by a lot of young people I've
been staggering these new statistics now
of people who really dislike Churchill
and have no respect for him
well I think it's partly uh the fact he
was built up to be such a big figure but
for me uh everything uh that has been
identified
um that Iman is talking about is
important and needs to be weighed into
the equation thank you Anthony that's
all I want that's what I want that or
because we are all
mixtures of good and bad every leader
and I think for young people to have the
evidence and weigh it up I'm just going
to mention three good things he did and
by the way I agree the treatment are in
uh of the kikuyu tribe in Kenya during
that period of suppressing Mao Mao was
utterly deployed seven years after World
War II it's from 1952 onwards uh uh but
this is what he did he did uh on the
welfare state he was a core person
building the welfare state before the
first world war and as prime minister in
the second world war he oversaw the
beverage report and encouraged it uh
which has been enormously the benefit
secondly he was the first politician to
spot
um the the end of the Cold War in 1953
he made an extraordinary speech after
the death of Stalin saying we can't
carry on as we were and sadly there was
uh what he did in the Second World War
or where Hitler six million Jews 50
million dead in that war he did stand up
when Britain was alone so
um to give young people uh the evidence
on both sides I'll let them come to
their own judgment and to recognize that
every leader out me you peers everyone
is a mixture of good and bad but not
mustard not monstrous and that's my
issue not everyone is a mixture of
monstrous and heroes we'll show you
about being monsters starting to
actually Crush take one of my house all
right take my one of my heroes like
Nelson Mandela he was on the no-fly list
for this country throughout most of the
70s right he was a man and many of you
to be a terrorist and then he came out
and he turned out to be one of the
all-time great peacemakers now again do
you take his life in totality Mandela or
do you say that actually anyone involved
in any form of activity which could be
clouds of terrorism is a monster and
therefore there is no chance for a
public figure to redeem Nelson Mandela
sanction making pliers that crushed and
ripped the testicles off of black men
did Nelson Mandela do that fizz what he
did sanction was he sanctioned activity
which by today's standards would be
construed as terrorists well so we can
safely say that yes everyone is in fact
I'm not negating that I think the issue
I think my point my point is that you
can take almost any historical figure
and you can paint a picture as Anthony
said of negative and positive to me what
Churchill achieved in World War II
overrides everything else but why though
so why does that supersede the fact that
he caused thousands tens of thousands of
black deaths and potentially again it's
it's arguable but potentially his
decision-making led to the deaths of
millions of Indians so what you're
saying but that's not the deaths but
okay so but what we can say
categorically is what I said about the
Kenyan concentration camp so if you
think that the Kenyan concentration
camps wasn't monstrous and what you're
doing is you're negating the thoughts
and feelings and expressions
anything that Churchill did on the
negative side I think a lot of the
things he said were certainly racially
tinged things that he did what about the
players I've just told you no no we're
not defending that at all right so and
that's the point we need to balance the
argument I agree with that yeah
I agree but where On Your Balanced
argument does the pendulum swing to
saving the world from the last I agree
no see this is the thing I'm not the
extremist I don't throw the baby out
with the bath water maybe you're used to
those types of guests here I'm not that
type of person I Believe In Balance so I
actually agree with you think he did
incredible things but I think it's also
important to acknowledge that he also
did really monstrous things and we
should present both arguments and allow
people to establish okay so the sheer
fact that we're having this discussion
now that that we are here able to talk
is because he led this country to stand
up against a fascist dictator who like
many of the leaders in the world today
many want to China Russia North Korea
and more want to squeeze free debate the
kind of discussion we have at the moment
we can go back have our separate lives
we're not going to be put in we wouldn't
be having it under Nazi Germans so
absolutely I'm not disputing so give
them the facts and I think that perhaps
it was inevitable there was so much
adulation of Churchill there's now a
steep and that's a that's a really
extraordinary figure eighty percent of
young people have a negative picture I
think that maybe in five years time it
will rebalance I I think myself will
disagree Imam on this that I think that
that it will be overwhelmingly positive
about Churchill while not ignoring the
downside and I think if people can learn
about Humanity then that that people's
flaws uh including you know what he did
or what he sanctioned as prime minister
uh in the 1950s in Kenya weigh all that
then that's real education that's what
history is about I mean there are proper
arguments to be had about the the carpet
bombing of Dresden in World War II which
many people think was completely
unacceptable Churchill would argue if he
was here he's not but if he was he would
argue it was a necessary evil to
facilitate the Hasting of the ending of
the war now a lot of people don't agree
with that historically but if you're a
wartime leader you've got to make
horrendous decisions decisions I totally
agree with you and I bring it back to
just having an inclusive mindset and I
think that's the issue here that many
people seem to not uh or let me just put
it this way I don't think people are
disputing the fact that he's here I
think that many people are disputing the
fact that he is also a monster and that
is where the problem lies appears I'm
not saying he's not a hero everything
that you've just said everything that
you just said I agree I think it's
awesome but I also have to take into
account that the Indian population that
died potentially because of his decision
making probably wouldn't have called him
a hero I have to take into account that
the men that were having their testicles
ripped from their bodies probably
wouldn't call Winston Churchill a hero
either so again it comes down to an
inclusive mentality when you take into
account everyone's feelings it becomes a
lot harder to then definitively say
someone as a hero or a villain what you
usually do is say they are both you take
into account they are racist you take
into account that they're a hero and you
take into account that they and so we
found upon Churchill uh that well I do I
think he sanctions some monstrous things
personally I don't think he was a
monster I think he had a deeply so
sanctioning monster compassionate things
doesn't make you a monster is that right
Anthony let's just make sure you're
clear do monstrous things you're not a
monster is that correct I think that is
that correct let me ask you a difficult
question do you think do you think the
unleashing of two nuclear weapons in
World War II uh Hiroshima and Nagasaki
was that justified was that monstrous
I think those types of things are
monstrous I don't think that kills
anyone answers okay so you're calling
that you're calling the American
president that did that a monster
another one that kills anyone else but
then you want to see it right but that
brought to an end a war that would have
killed many many many more people but it
still doesn't negate the fact that it
was monstrous to the people that died
and that's what I'm trying to say what
about your feelings and white people's
feelings and Jewish about white people's
feelings above everyone else that had a
negative
see that I think you let yourself down
when you say white people British people
Jewish people the people I typically
this is where I'm coming from the people
that I typically find defend Winston
Churchill there have been many blacks
let's be honest with ourselves here but
I typically find it's majority white
because we have this this real kind of
um admiration for the man and so a lot
of people because he saved us from now
after taking consideration I don't think
anybody thinks the Winston nobody thinks
he was an angel at all but he took a lot
of very difficult decisions people are
negating the fact that he is monster
that is the issue be balanced all right
your major point you made your point uh
Anthony I want to just yeah talk to you
quickly about your book The Path of
Peace walking the Western Front way
couldn't be more timely obviously
remembrance Sunday this weekend when you
wrote This Book
have we learned the lessons that led to
the catastrophe of the first world war
do you think so uh no categorically not
I mean as I was walking that the third
world war was uh in Ukraine perhaps
about to unfold it was the vision of a
young Soldier peers who uniquely it
would seem had a vision on building a
path to peace which I think is
fundamental where we can have people his
vision was of all Nations or all face or
backgrounds walking side by side
together to try to learn from the dead
from both sides so I walked back last
summer a thousand kilometers a million
Paces through soil where 10 million 10
million had bled to death or had their
lives totally wrecked uh in the effort
of trying to build a path to BC was an
extraordinary uh Visionary
um uh young young man and so no but it
is by building understanding Building
Bridges with each other and think maybe
not rushing myself to condemn other
people to understand why they did things
that we have the best Hope For Humanity
and that's exactly why I wrote the book
on the Western Front way now is the
world's biggest commemoration project
everyone can walk it or cycle it
um it's going to become like the
northern uh Camino I think it was the
best idea to come out of the first world
war appears even though it categorically
hasn't ended the second world well
didn't stop the second world war and
when what other hope is there unless we
just walk together respect our
difference and indeed love each other
for our difference which is an inclusive
mentality by the way well I think we've
respected each other's differences thank
you someone goes for us that we love
each other yet but the United States
great to see you Imani thank you very
much for coming in I appreciate it